hello and welcome to our web talk
europeans head to the polls and you
so we're going to be looking at what
europeans make of these elections and
whether they'll be voting or not
joining me are thomas panaya tupulos and
he is from greece
hello thomas hello hello
and next to him is anna prakona and
she's from the czech republic hi anna
hello
right and we also have our mobile
reporter in the field her name's miriam
but um she's in the field there if you
see the little image um next to anna and
thomas and then next to them is um
um professor ludga coonhat and he's
joining us from the center of european
integration studies hello professor
hello
and then we also have joseph finn who's
joining us from middlesbrough england
hello hello joseph
and finally we want you guys to take
part in this discussion so we have our
social media editor and sophie brendlin
hi there um yeah you can send us your
tweets and comments on facebook on
google plus or on twitter
and i will show the sign here if there's
any comments from you guys and then i
can include them so why don't you start
right now and tell us if you're going to
vote or not
exactly and while you guys try to figure
out whether you're voting or not and
telling us that on twitter we're gonna
show you this video that our mobile
reporter miriam klausner made she went
and asked the people in bonn whether
they'll be voting
um yes of course because it's important
to use your voice especially when you're
young and you want to change something
in the world yeah i'm going to vote
because it's important
to
go voting for the european network and
to build up something like knowledge
exchange for the students of course i go
to the election because in my opinion if
you don't go voting then you don't have
a right to complain no um
i
i want a boat because i'm from spain and
i think that
we have an
honorable politicians and
i i am very
disagree with i am not i really disagree
with this politician i already wanted
and
the reason is in other countries people
are dying for their rights for voters
yes i'm going to vote and i think it's
very important because um i want to be
part of the decisions that i'm going to
take in the european union i'm from
bulgaria
and i don't want to vote because
i know what's happened in bulgaria the
people vote
and
after the same people
yes i decided
to vote because assistant of europa i
want to take part of the integration of
europa
right so we heard what people in bonn
had to say about voting it looks like
most of them will be voting in these
elections
um but we had two people two young
people who say they won't be full they
won't be voting and there's one of them
who's from spain and she um i mean she
said that she won't be voting um spain
and greece have a lot in common in terms
of the european economic crisis thomas
so maybe you could tell us whether
you're voting or not
because
i'll be definitely voting because for me
it's important
to to
show to everyone that
if you're not participating anything
even though you're disagreeing you will
never change anything so it's important
to vote first of all
secondly i can understand that a lot of
young people from these
countries which have
are in the economic crisis in europe
southern countries usually spend
younger people are depressed because of
unemployment in these countries i can
understand that but
they should still go and vote if they
want to change something right so you
think of course the best way to protest
is also by voting what about young
people from the czech republic anna is
it similar i mean how do they feel about
voting in the eu elections
well i think that young people in czech
republic they are quite eager to vote
however
um still only around 27 to 30 of the
whole population of czech republic go
and vote for the european election which
i still think is a very low turnout so
i would only suggest for everyone not
even young people just to go and vote
because then people complain and if they
don't vote they shouldn't really be
complaining so you are taking your
voting yourself
um joseph
the uk began was voting today i mean
like netherlands they are the two first
countries to be voting in these eu
elections
have you been out to vote yet
not yet i'm going to go to vote after
this discussion
and um
i'm really looking forward to voting
because i've just turned 18 this year so
it'll be my first time that i can vote
but what i've noticed at my college is
that nobody's talking about the european
elections so
i can't see there being a big turnout in
the european elections here right oh so
why are you voting i mean it doesn't
seem to be a big deal where you are so
why have you decided to vote
well there's a party called ukip which
are a euro skeptic party and they're uh
getting a lot of
support at the moment
but i'd i'd like to stay in the european
union so i won't use my vote um
to support a party who wants to stay in
the eu too
do you know anyone who's voting for you
kip
uh yes i do i do know some friends here
are they young people like yourself or
are they much older
um i think the majority
would probably be older than me
um
but also that there will be some young
people the the problem with ukip is that
we we don't get a lot of information
about the eu here and ukip have used a
lot of campaigns that have used figures
that are a bit misleading and people
have been misled by that all right all
right well it seems we have a comment
from social media so maybe we'll just
take that comment from ann sophie uh now
let's hear what people are saying
yeah we actually have someone else who
wants to vote for youtube and that
created quite some backlash on our uh
google plus discussion i can show you
guys um
his name is anthony drake and he says
that he's definitely voting tomorrow he
can't wait and he's saying that euclid
is gonna get his vote not just because
of the eu but all of their policies
answer his concerns we need to be out of
this eu nonsense asap
and he keeps going why because of you
know speed limits and
a lot of regulations and then we have a
ton of comments it really created a lot
of backlash as you can see
and yeah so there's actually quite some
people out there who will vote for you
right um let's turn to professor
kuhnhardt um
you've just heard
the talk about ukip and it's not the
only right-wing party in europe that's
been gaining popularity there's also
four national in france there's hurt
builders party in the netherlands i mean
why is it that we see a lot of support
for these parties and do you expect
people to turn out in high numbers to
vote for them in these countries
well i think first of all we have to put
all this into a context
on
may 25 we have two elections in europe
the election in the ukraine takes place
in the shadow of people running around
with kalashnikovs in the eu we have free
elections which includes the right of
people not to vote and it includes the
right
of people to to be critical about
certain regulations you mentioned speed
limits or even about the whole eu as
such this is an expression of the
free and democratic system we live in
and i understand that
most of those people who are
labeled euroskeptics these days
if at all they have one thing in common
they all realize that europe
is getting serious that european
integration and
interdependencies among our societies
are getting serious and um they are
afraid of losing their identity or even
some national power so in a way this
wave
euro skepticism my view is uh explicable
but i think it is not going to derail
the european path of integration all
right well maybe let's just turn to
miriam and see what people in bonn are
saying i mean maybe i don't know if
there's support for such parties but we
we could just turn to miriam to see what
people are saying uh at least on the
streets of bonn
of course not everyone in the park is
talking about the european elections but
i bumped into a group of erasmus
students
and they were just discussing the
biggest problems young people are facing
in their countries unfortunately they
had to go to a lecture so i've just to
summarize what they told me
and i met two girls from france they
were saying there's no proper job in
france or they will certainly not find a
proper job when they finish their
studies
um i met a girl from greece she was
saying she doesn't see any future in
greece um
she will not get a proper job there and
all her friends are looking for jobs
abroad and then there was a guy from
spain he was pretty disappointed with
the spanish system
he says he is not able to finish his phd
in spain because um there are no
university grants anymore and from your
discussion um they would like to know
i'd like to know are the problems that
people were mentioning only specific to
their countries
right so i mean we have with us here
three young people and uh one from the
uk and then of course thomas was from
greece and germany and also anna who's
from the czech republic maybe i'll start
with anna anna are these problems
similar to those of young people in the
czech republic
uh yes i think not to that much extent
but i think there are still some
problems that young people in czech
republic are facing
especially if they are studying uh
many humanitarian humanities like we are
politics or anything
so that there is a really high
unemployment and i think people would
like to think and they do complain about
and use it
and um what about um
well for greece i don't know how much
content you have with people in greece
uh thomas maybe you could just tell us
about what young people in greece may uh
your friends especially may be saying
what your report had just reported from
the center of bond where she met the
greek girl
and
is a bit the picture of the greek youth
today and
especially students they don't see any
opportunities in their countries but
this is something from friends from
greece italy and spain i hear it it's
it's
the idea that the only way is to get out
of their countries and get to
to move somewhere else to find a job so
and if this has repercussions on the
idea they have about the european union
that the european union is not
seen
by these persons as a place where you
can have
multiple possibilities and
but
it's seen as
a as a european union where
where you only have opportunities
outside of your country which is a bit
um
a bit the truth at the moment in in
these countries but uh i think this is
the major problem the european union
should tackle if
this youth young people should uh should
change your mind right well i mean what
about you joseph um i just want to know
from you because you are in a country
that actually might want out of the eu
yes how are young people you know how do
they perceive the eu do they see it as a
place where they can move for work or do
they just see it as a waste of money i
mean your friends especially we have
contact with
well i think miriam mentioned that in
certain countries there are problems
with funding for university and a few
years ago the university fees were
raised by quite a bit uh here in the uk
but i think a good thing from that is
that we get a lot of grants to help
poorer students go to university
so i don't think
we have this idea that europe can be
somewhere where we could go and study
unless you were a language student or
maybe a student who was doing something
specific
like biochemistry or something that you
would need to go abroad to uh
to uh large in your your opportunities
all right
um professor kuhnet we just heard three
uh well two rather more similar opinions
from two young people and then one that
was fairly different from the uk
what kind of effect are such uh
perceptions of the eu having on the
voting patterns that we may see in these
elections in these different countries
well i think the basic uh effect of all
of this is that people no matter whether
they go voting or not no matter they
vote mainstream parties or you're
skeptical is the overall fact is that
all of them all of us in europe want to
see a european union that works the
european union that takes people
concerns seriously the european union
that translates the destiny and
the vocation of this european union to
be a union of peace
into
sustainable economic growth and social
stability following from the provision
of new jobs for young people in
particular
all right well we have a comment from
social media so we'll turn to and sophie
and just um if you could just let us
know what people are saying on twitter
yeah i mean we heard a lot of your
skeptical voices but we're also getting
some comments from people that actually
really believe in the eu and also really
believe in voting um let me show you
some of them
so one is benjamin beckham from germany
who's saying he already voted via mail
because the same can't stand silent and
see
extremists and propagandist tear up the
eu
someone referred to his post his name is
willem from holland and he's saying
voting is both a democratic obligation
and a personal responsibility to
influence your own future
and we have a third comment from someone
from germany who's saying yes he wants
to vote for federal europe with a common
language and army no nato and russia
somehow should be part of it
well these are the comments that we're
getting from our users right now so
right you we heard that um what about
you professor i have a rather short
question to ask you have you been
encouraging students to vote in these
elections
yes of course and i feel encouraged by
the direction of many of our students
here at my institute they are all either
to
turn their educational
background and professional experience
into
jobs that help to bring europe forward i
think this is the overall spirit of a
vast majority of young people they want
to contribute to the well-being of their
respective societies and in doing so
they contribute to the common goods of
europe these days we talk so much but
sometimes even too much about euro
skeptics in in our media
i'm not against discussing these
phenomena but we should keep in mind
that the vast majority of europeans who
go out voting vote for the mainstream
parties who are forming for a good
number of years they have been doing so
some sort of a grand question in this
european institutions maybe some people
find this boring i understand very well
the grand coalition always produces a
certain boredom but it guarantees that
europe works that the institutions work
and these working institutions must take
the issue seriously which we have been
discussing here youth unemployment in
the first place otherwise europe is in
in
in danger to even increase the number of
euro skeptics in the years ahead
right um maybe let's just have a little
mini vault uh for our guests um how
who is if you if you feel positively
about the eu and the future of the eu
please raise your arm
so
okay
we have okay the professor didn't seem
so sure there
sure um maybe i'll pick one of the
students uh maybe anna just tell us why
you're positive
i think
now the young generations are actually
realizing that europe is important and
work together even with the happenings
in ukraine the europe needs to take one
approach and work as one
i don't want to say coalition as a union
to work together towards a better future
and i think especially i would say with
my colleagues here at
in my class or even with my friends back
home in czech republic they realized
that just to work together for a better
future is the way to go
all right and professor you are hesitant
and so i just want you to tell us why
you hesitated
well no because i thought you were only
asking the young people to to
react to your uh to your question and i
thought i am
not really any longer part of this
generation but i am this european public
and uh have strong opinions about a good
future of europe and and want the
european union to succeed for all
generations
because this is an intergenerational
project it is a community of values that
brings us together after a century of
warfare and in light of all the
challenges we see around us in light of
all the human rights violations around
the world in light also of the
contributions
of europe to increase the level of
social cohesion i think the european
project is worth continuing and doing so
with a stronger democratic
outlook and this is what all these
elections what these elections are all
about to give europe uh more of a face
to personalize and to politicize this
process which is not bureaucratic alone
but really uh helps us understanding the
future path of our european society
let's let's turn back to ann sophie and
let's see what people have been saying
on twitter
yeah we have one user who would really
would like to to vote but she can't and
she would um as the reason why when we
asked her
her name is katie burton she's from the
uk and she hasn't um been in the uk for
more than 15 years because she's working
in austria so she's saying no vote for
me in new elections she was
disenfranchised disenfranchised in the
uk
and it's too late for her to vote in
austria and then in another post she
said that that's one of the reasons um
the complex sign up that she would like
to actually take on the german
nationality
because that's how much he actually
wants to vote
right
well we have anna and thomas uh two
people who are actually in germany and
you have other foreign foreign friends
studying here i believe
how many of them are not voting because
of just how complicated it is
i think i think generally um there is
a big um
all the whole subject about voting and
all about people of the european union
being abroad voting is very complex and
a lot to get confused about
how and where and
if they could or not vote we had a
discussion before at lunchtime with a
lot of people and it was funny because
everyone has had his opinion about
um who could vote and not but uh yeah
there is a confusion and i think this
comes from the fact that
the european elections
are based in every country with the laws
of every country and i think uh a common
european election law would be a good
would go in the good direction to
to put inside this whole confusion and
to show to the european people that they
can that we are truly a union and they
they can easily vote even abroad
right well yeah i mean that's obviously
the problem with the eu because there's
you know 28 different countries now 28
electoral systems that people have to
deal with and of course for europeans
living in different european countries
that becomes very complicated um maybe
we i have one final question which i'd
like all of you to answer um say imagine
that you were elected into the eu
parliament what's the one thing that you
would change the first thing that you
would change in europe i will start with
joseph
um i would like to see
more
renewable energies used
uh because
i think we need to take care of future
generations
and that there needs to be more
investment in uh
in things like wind energy and sun
energy for the future
all right and now let's turn to
professor coonhat uh what what's the one
thing that you would change
well i would change the right to have
the right to change something personally
because i believe europe only works if
we all work together and
not on the basis of an autocratic system
as we see it developing in russia these
days europe depends on consensus among
its citizens and i would always stand
there to give even opponents the right
to speak their free mind
all right let's turn to anna what would
you change
well i do agree with professor dunhart
and also
uh better transparency within
some european institution would actually
be quite helpful for the citizens
because many citizens and i can say from
the czech republic don't know anything
about the european institutions or
what's going on and how
how do they
make legislations or anything like that
so transparency and inform the citizens
of the union more
right and thomas finally
i would change a lot in the promotion of
the european union because i think that
a lot have been a lot has been achieved
since the beginning of this european
idea and it's still not well promoted
and this gives
space for
eurosceptics and people who are
misinformed to to to advance and to
mislead people
because
we should also know that the european
union is
an an idea which is very attractive for
a lot of countries around europe who um
like i don't know georgia serbia and
others who would like to be part of this
european idea and i think that the
promotion of the european idea should be
something we should we should
concentrate in the next year
all right well a few different ideas
there but let's see what you guys have
been saying on social media and sophie
uh yeah one of our users
okay
i heard this little backlash so um one
of our users is actually saying that one
thing that he would like to change um
are the amounts the massive amount of
regulations that the eu has
and he wrote us and said he voted
against the eu because of these
regulations because the eu is english or
nurturing which in german means um it's
really not necessary he says the eu was
a good idea but done as a chaos it only
costs time and money and um he really is
against all these quote stupid
regulations and the people who actually
make them so um yeah the regulations
really seem to bother some of our users
right so um
some people think that the eu is not as
important but i mean obviously the best
way for them to make their opinion known
is perhaps to go out and vote
so um we've come to the end of this
hangout and i'd like to thank you all of
our guests for joining us today thank
you
um
and for the rest of you you can
obviously join our discussion on social
media because that will continue just
remember to use the hashtag dwebtalk
otherwise please visit our europe
special at dw.de
europe 2014.